breaking it for two people are dead six
injured after being stabbed on the Las
Vegas Strip on the sidewalk in front of
the wind this is a live look at the area
where the stabbing occurred roads were
closed for hours some have opened back
up but others remain blocked off causing
a huge backup on I'm 15 southbound thank
you for joining us at four I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Christian Casitas as you
just heard Sheriff Lombardo say the
suspect is in custody and the strip is
secure but we're told that the man
accused in the stabbings used a large
kitchen knife to carry out the attacks
our crew has been on the scene for hours
and we do have team coverage tonight
Ryan Matthey is live on the Strip but
first Sasha Loftus joins us live at
Metro Police Headquarters after they
have just wrapped up a press conference
Sasha catch us up
Christian and Kirsten of those eight
people stabs were told two are dead one
is in critical condition tonight now
police say this attack was unprovoked
and the suspect does not appear to be
from Las Vegas now officers tell us that
suspect who has been identified as a
Hispanic man in his 30s stabbed those
eight people unprovoked again on the
side of the east side of Las Vegas
Boulevard near Sands Avenue this video
you see here shows the man running from
the scene he was later brought into
custody a few hundred feet away from
that original crime scene during today's
news conference police shared sympathy
as well for the families of the victims
killed today
we want to extend our heartfelt
condolences to the families of the
victims and to the victims themselves
this is clearly a very tragic and hard
to understand hard to comprehend uh
murder investigation that deeply impacts
our community
now officers so want to make it clear
in the public more information as soon
as possible police say they will be
giving us more updates as they can so of
course stay with eight news now as this
continues to develop